31 of our fellow Americans just brutally
slaughtered in these massacres which
should not have happened and I'm not
talking about a utopian version of every
person being nice to each other I'm
talking about a realist view of these
shooters both of them should have been
identified before they committed their
acts of violence and yet our society
once again we saw this in parkland and
now again in El Paso and in Dayton they
should have been stopped because they
exhibited red flags and yet they were
ignored
certainly in Dayton there were a lot of
red flags it may have been a little
harder to identify the El Paso shooter
but but certainly in Dayton for years at
this point it should have been clear
that this guy was a danger to himself
and to others and President Trump
I thought hit the nail on the head in
his statement which is we need to not
only have a conversation about mental
health which is the same line you hear
after every mass shooting but we need to
make it easier to involuntarily commit
those who are crazy those who have
mental illnesses and those who might
pose a danger to themselves or to others
we used to do this in this country it
was a successful program then in the
1960s and 70s we got rid of the mental
institutions and let people out even
some of the leaders the pioneers of
letting the inmates out of the mental
institutions later came to realize we
let too many people out at the time the
logic was that there were a lot of
psychiatric drugs that would now allow
people to be cured the trouble was they
got out and they they no longer took
those drugs and as a result of that era
it's not very difficult to commit people
or to strip them of their civil rights
if they are not capable of using their
liberty as we certainly see in the case
of these shooters it is I think pretty
irresponsible of the left to blame this
these attacks on the right I mean first
of all one of the attackers the one in
Ohio was an avowed socialist and leftist
and a supporter of Elizabeth Warren
so that's ridiculous and then the
shooter in in Texas was an eco fascist
so that's a bizarre ideology that
includes the fringes of the right end of
the left I just think it's really
cynical I think it's exploitative of the
left to do that you see this from
everyone from presidential candidates
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders you see
in congressmen like AOC you see this in
the pod save America bros like Dan
Pfeiffer and what's so egregious is
those left-wing organizations are now
coming against President Trump who has
repeatedly condemned racism and bigotry
they're coming after political pundits
and commentators the media matters was
going after me earlier today it's really
disgusting you know you're talking about
over 30 of your fellow Americans whose
bodies are not yet cold and for the left
to exploit that for it for an untrue
political point and political goal is is
really shameful and if they could feel
shame they should be ashamed of
themselves well to use the left's
favourite word it's unprecedented I mean
just a couple years ago if something
terrible like a shooting happened the
left told us that we couldn't even talk
about the politics of the thing for days
on end and now not only are we talking
about the politics immediately the left
is allowed somehow to tell lies about
their political opponents to try to
exploit a tragedy for their own
political agenda that is the definition
of despicable that is exploitation
that's exploiting people's grief and
fear which is the most disgusting type
of exploitation